j'ai joué un jeu toute la journée au
bureau c'est très simple voilà je vous
le dis c'est que en fait c'est le carte
bleue challenger je fais glisser ma
carte bleue ah oui un et vous devez
l'arrêter avec la tête
orio c'est exceptionnel j'ai fait ça
mais qu'ils avaient il faut se mettre à
jour ni d'accord et l'arrêter avec sa
tête c'est en tout cas la tête
ouais avec la tête comme sanofi non mais
arrêtez celui qu'il arrête si vous
voulez jouer avec moi je lui passe ma
carte bleue pendant une heure n'ont pas
fait ce qu'il veut à deux pas vraiment
fait ce qu'il peut avec le code et tous
je vous donne pendant une heure et demie
mais alors est ce qui peut laisser
tomber ou blanc si on perd à lomé sous
garde les quatre heures d'imola rien là
bas les regarder regardez regardez
l'exemple
voyez pas ce matin attention ça peut
servir
j'ai fait ça j'ai
c'est ma vraie carte bleue ou mots durs
c'est vrai regardez vous étiez vous avez
réglé la médaille me regarder les gamins
vraie carte mais on a juste voilà bien
sachez le coffre c'est ma vraie carte
bleue d'un civil à new york on n'a juste
pas la cacher j'utiliserai thaler vous
allez voir mais la raison vous avez
réussi à le faire vous alors attention
ici c'est tout pas moi j'ai déjà ma
carte mère avait déjà réussi à la récup
alors attention attention bref j'ai dit
aux dirigeants avaient trop loin jam un
chat était déjà trop loin faut vraiment
quoi toi chose qu'il est près de huy
veut aller là m attention tu es prêt non
une deuxième chance de peut être un peu
plus longtemps chez nous tu l'auras pas
et je vais entendre ton front dans ton
caisse nollet contre la page web
non mais mon corps des gardes n'ont pas
compris la seule médaille je n'arrive
pas à mettre un genou le match aller
jean michel et moi on va pas l'applaudir
parce que c'est lever web
attention non parce que l'ong à moi
c'est maintenant la lépi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
doucement j'ai envie d'avoir à 3e et
attendait l'association les roseaux
sauvages et pas mal à temps dans la
plaie près mais je vois quand on a 20 2
[Applaudissements]
ces habitations au terminal à ottawa
avec jean le temps qu'ils allaient
christine kelly bah oui je sais ça
paraît simple de sexuel il prépare toi
n'importe laquelle il s'arrête à toi sa
part atteint labatut de leurs moubarak
pâture à mon chéri va regarder le jeu tu
peux le garder mais tu peux gagner ma
carte sim après carte bleue en naviguant
dans une heure si vous arrivez le celui
karila macabre d'un milliard et puis ce
qui va avec
il ya un match avec ta carte c'est pas
plus de 15 millions d'euros de dépenses
par hors jeu se renseigner auprès de sa
banque
allez allez je vous rappelle que
regarder christine kelly du sell in may
cry et il regarde vers 3 2 ou 3 2 1
non mais
regardez regardez la politique s'il
regarde c'est mieux célia qui viennent
va la voir ça n'allait kenya allez je
sais pas je suis bien allé louche bon se
pose à tout ce que tu vas pouvoir
acheter
même si elle perd on est content quand
même du résultat mais faites attention à
votre bon coeur il dit 3 2 1
l'annoncé est facile tu atteindras but
par villa il est malin j'ai fait ça car
ces attentions
mais il faut toujours que c'est pas vrai
car tard car t'es pas sérieux avis tu as
toujours au [ __ ] si je lâche up s'est
passé à cet égard est les seuls qui
soient réglés c'est l'époque de l'homme
avec l'eau monte a et b c'est drôle
parce que pour le chignon à laval m est
là pour se [ __ ] la tête dans la porte
pour avoir une carte bleue ça dérange
pas du tout faits bah si c'est ok on
respecte les personnes riches deux faits
loire essonne et vous collait trop beau
trop gras trouvait ce qu'on va donc que
les travaux n'étaient pas touchés pab
attention tellement à voir n'est pas que
je dois aller manger
dommage on recommence pas une troisième
alors vous mettez sur le quotidien d'un
petit peu de temps vous rappellera t il
d'accord merci à et épanouie est ce que
tu me le suis je le seul lucide pour
savoir que si on proposait je la sais
qu'on va tous perdre pas dues à la panne
et d'où ils avaient allait bien taisho
battant c'est pas elle est très ligue 1
arrive là cattrall est elle folle on
sait le dentier l'accessible aquantive
yeux raconte moi la ola voilà un peu
toute sa tête vous êtes mariés en
poissons
la pause est folle c'est ma vie ici m'a
mis là je sais pas jeter des shows la
pharmacie a les arbres un grand coup la
carta les parterres de plus tu vas
parraitre d'arthur van damme isabelle
j'adore la droite reçoit ces deux modes
préfère métro tu colles ton monte ton
chéri c'est parce que je peux qu alex à
la poitrine sorte parce que si tu
bloques avec le menton s'est perdu qu'un
qui prend l'antenne comme ça c'est bien
c'était deux doigts ouais ça fait quatre
fois que tu as deux doivent aller de
leurs maux photo al et mathieu et moi
j'ai les attentions et l'oseille ces
mêmes métiers l'avait pas j'arrête avec
ce que je veux maintenant et unsa les
maths
eux veulent faire tu peux y aller quant
à ta ta ta bouche pas bouge pas les
regardait faut que tu regardes bien
regarder victoire tôt sociaux thomas je
regarde la carte facture david et moi
j'ai pas regardé maintenant que je joue
laissez moi faire les gars sur ce
domaine là et sur un bon trend en poster
jour sort vraiment quelqu'un atteint
force je vais commander un mac à la
tension est forte comme la peau
vas-y mat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ris je vais te dire d'aller de faire
jeter en mer et je me sens tu peux
t'asseoir mais attention n'est pas le
droit d'utiliser internet
alors je vous explique ici nous sommes
là sur place si vous passez au p geo
plaisir mais je le dis
j'avais ma carte pendant une heure ce
matin on pouvait pas quitter plateau
[Rires]
vous n'avez pas moi d'utiliser internet
à bonnard et le point de fausser pour la
regarder
bah oui bah vous avez je crois que
maintenant je suis riche donc comme je
t'emmerde
mais ma carte pour d'ailleurs mais pas
vraiment une heure on joue sa
gentillesse que jean foot sinon ouais
c'est ce que c'était le deal